hey guys today I'm going to talk about
possibility that might happen in the
weather last season but the theory that
show already might have given us a few
hints about a possibility of the nearest
becoming the new night's queen before I
jump into those kind of prove that are
supporting the theory I'm going to tell
you a few sentences about the night
screen so you could have an insight of
what Dana might become the night's Queen
is unseen woman in Game of Thrones a
legendary figure known in the Seven
Kingdoms and among the free folk
according to legend Lord Commander of
the Nights Watch found in haunted forest
the cold woman with bright blue eyes he
took her to the other side of the wall
and declared himself as the night's king
their love and reign lasted for 13 years
whereupon the free folk rallied under
the banner of a king-beyond-the-wall and
marched against the night's king seed
against the knife fort which resulted
the night's king defeat with the aid of
how stark now that you know a little bit
about the night screen let's start with
attire in which the neighbors who become
the same queen for past six years we
could predict what will happen in every
season with a few surprises of course
for example we knew the Danish dragons
would be born that steering's going to
kill his father and we knew that jon is
going to be killed as well informations
which we move together from George RR
Martin's A Song of Ice and Fire series
of epic fantasy novels in all of these
years we could predict a few things that
will happen in the next episode or in
the next season but we can tell the same
for season 7 not to mention for the last
a season in the history that I'm
bringing today would take place Game of
Thrones is known for its
unpredictability and we are at the point
on the show in which big amount of major
plots have already been revealed and
while we might have our opinions what is
going to happen based on either our
experience with game film series Oren
leagues that have been leaked or the
last five months
we might be totally wrong for example we
can tell for sure that search syndrome
will become allies and that we are going
to see a meeting between ice and fire
between Jon Snow and the Near East in
the first few episodes of season 7
but while big amount of fans would
predict the nearest conquest over the
Seven Kingdoms and over the Iron Throne
on this she would said since she has
strongest army the world has seen since
the fall
Valyria which makes her goal of
conquering the Seven Kingdoms quite
easier I'm not of the same opinion in my
opinion Daenerys despite of her three
large dragons and the biggest army that
she has I don't think that she is going
to be a new Aegon the conquerer I don't
think that she will ever sit on the Iron
Throne if we have learned anything from
games turns serious in all these years
and the only thing that we can
doubtlessly expect on the upcoming
seasons is the wow factor that Game of
Thrones is known for known for its
unpredictability while you might expect
that Daenerys is going to conquer the
Seven Kingdoms defeat Cersei and sit on
the Iron Throne I'm predicting only then
is defeat over Cersei while she won't
sit on the Iron Throne additionally
while you think the Daenerys will be a
queen and rule over the Seven Kingdoms
I'm predicting the nares being Queen as
well but being denied screened earlier
in Game of Thrones we've learned that
the leader of the White Walkers aka
tonight King is able to create a white
Walker but it seems that he only can
create one if that human being is the
pure-blooded or incest born as some kind
of proof we have a few scenes in which
Craster had been sacrificing his incest
born babies including a scene from
fourth season in which Roz places
Craster's final son on the ground in the
haunted forest rip on White Walkers
approached and took the baby carried it
towards shattered mountain in the lands
of always winter once a white Walker
approached an eye shelter ringed by
large I see spikes he plays the baby
upon the altar for upon the leader of
the White Walkers approached gently
gathered the baby in his arms and place
his index finger upon the baby's cheek
which caused the child side to turn icy
blue and it's came to grow pale this
scene from the fourth episode of season
4 in my opinion confirmed my statement
that only incest born pure blooded human
beings can become a white Walker while
every other human beings can only become
a white a reanimated corpse raised from
the dead by the white walkers to act as
their minions all of this means that the
night's king could turn Denarius into
one of them since then is pure blooded
incest born daughter of King Aerys and
Queen rhaella Targaryen the greatest war
the only important war is not coming any
more is here just like winter that had
been coming since the very first season
the winter is here
now and the only way to end the long
night is to either defeat them which
would be insanely hard evaded living
side is definitely going to experience
way which will take a huge amount of
casualties the way which will only make
the undead army bigger then so brave
soldiers that are going to fall on the
battlefield against the undead army to
be revived as the whites in my opinion
the only way that living side will have
at that point will be attacked an
agreement with the leader of the undead
army and the same pact by this theory
would be a pact of Ice and Fire
an agreement that includes Daenerys I
was wondering why is the night king even
coming south why is he preparing an army
same army with which he is going to
march south at the moment of the nurses
arrival in the upcoming season I was
wondering about that fact since the last
season ended and came to conclusion that
the nurses arrival at Westeros is reason
of the night King's preparations and
will be the reason of his march will be
the reason of every single death that
the Seven Kingdoms is going to confront
with this theory in which the night king
is coming south for denied screen might
have been hinted earlier in the Game of
Thrones series I'm talking about any
solutions that she had in the house of
undying those same illusions that might
have for shared of this theory in a
series of illusions of some kind of
visions that she was greeted with the
first room Daenerys entered after
chasing the cry of her dragons into the
house of the undying was a great hole of
the red key which was covered by snow
including the Iron Throne whereupon she
got so close to the throne by decided to
leave it untouched and went beyond the
wall where she found herself in another
illusion in which emerged from the wall
in a snowstorm
whereupon she entered the tent and met
with Drogo and their son Rhaego burping
she became aware of delusion and left
the first part of illusion in which
Damian toward the Great Hall of the red
keep which was covered by snow I would
say foreshadow something that I said in
one of my previous videos predict that
the nurse'll and search his reign will
defeat two biggest villains and the
l'aventure family while she will win the
Iron Throne she won't be able to sit on
same since the winter will come along
with the White Walkers center white
horde where upon the near so decide to
march with your dragons and armies north
to join forces to John
now to give a links I'd hope hope that
her three dragons might end the long
night surely there will be more than a
few epic battles between the living and
the dead in the final season which I
guarantee prediction which I can't tell
for sure considering that the last
season will have the biggest budget of
any season budget that will be spent for
only six episodes which will provide an
epic battle so on with a lot of dragon
actions those battles between the Lynx
side and the White Walkers accompanied
with the right horde will take a lot of
casualties for both sides but every
casualty of the undead army will be
replaced with a casualty of the winning
side since all their soldiers that are
going to sacrifice their life on the
battlefield in order to stop the night
king and his army will be raised from
the dead and will increase the numbers
of the undead army will decrease chances
for living cycling the greatest war upon
a huge amount of casualties and upon
realizing that their chances to survive
the long night or small if there will be
any drink side will decide to stop
fighting and will try to establish peace
you'll try to arrange a [ __ ] to the
leader of the white walkers now we're
coming to a pact that I mentioned
earlier in this video a pact between the
links side and the night King an
agreement which Daenerys will accept to
end a long night a pact image she will
become the night screen an agreement
which will save the Westeros sacrifice
which Daenerys the true queen will
accept to save her people's lives
the nurses illusions are foreshadowing
that Danny will win the Iron Throne but
you'll realize that she won't be able to
sit on the same since you'll have to
give up on it since she will give up her
own for the greater good she will accept
the pact to the knight king in order to
end the long night
Daenerys will become a nice clean rope
on the night king and the night's Queen
will go beyond the wall and rule over it
as a form of peace agreement between the
living and the dead beside a nurse's
vision as I've already said earlier in
this video
there is revival at Westeros and the
night King's preparations and his march
to the south fits perfectly in timeline
and I don't think in coincidence that
all of those years the night team was
preparing and gathering huge army with
which he is going to march south at the
same time of Danny's arrival at Westeros
not only that this theory would be one
of the greatest surprises that
showrunners could
loud but it would also fit perfectly
with the bittersweet ending that George
Martin announced in conclusion I can't
tell for sure that this year will
definitely come true and that I'll just
figure out the ending but in my opinion
if the knight King is really marching
south because of Daenerys
nothing will be able to stop him and his
large army nothing but an agreement
which Danny would most certainly accept
in order to stop the long night to save
the Westeros from a certain annihilation
let me know your opinion on this theory
let me know what your thoughts are about
the knight Kings intentions and goals
along with your opinion about Danny's
illusions or visions I'm curious what
you guys think about all of this and
yeah also I want to congratulate bread
Jay preventing a giveaway for winning
hundred dollar and the neat card in a
few days I might announce another
giveaway so stay tuned and don't forget
to leave your comment about today's
theory I hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you did please make sure to
subscribe to our Channel and I hope to
see in the next one peace
[Music]
you